[Music]
a new voice is filling chicago's wrigley
field this season and he's making
history
jeremiah paparazzi recently made his
debut as the cubs new pa announcer
the 21 year old's the youngest ever to
take the mic for the cubs
he's also the first team's black
announcer adriana diaz shows us how his
success is resonating with fans
returning to great american pastimes
comes with the nostalgic
soundtrack at the ballpark
it's an organ and a voice from above
good afternoon
and welcome to baseball here at
beautiful wrigley field
and at wrigley that booming voice is
younger than it sounds
this is the voice of wrigley field
jeremiah paprocki
your voice sounds like you're like 58
years old
but how old are you actually i'm 21.
yeah
21 and still in college finishing up his
senior year remotely
i thought that this dream was out of the
ballpark but here i am in the ballpark
as the voice so
anything can happen so where's your new
office i'm in the press box
jeremiah paparaki is the youngest public
address announcer
ever at wrigley home to legendary
play-by-play broadcaster harry carey
and super fans like bill murray who
sometimes
takes the mic but paparazzi is also the
team's first
ever black pa announcer it really means
a lot
you know the social climate hasn't been
the best
and to have my story alone bring a lot
of positivity people of color in general
reaching out and saying like hey you're
such a huge inspiration
an inspiration congratulations man
appreciate it it's awesome
thank you who's now a bit of a sports
star of his own
he's killing it and i'm certainly happy
for him professor fred mitchell the
chicago tribune's first black sports
writer
so this is my card from 1983 wow when i
first started out
says the selection of paparazzi
highlights an even larger issue
just the attention that this hiring is
receiving
tells baseball to take a look at
themselves and
and say well you know how dive first are
we i think there's a lot of improvement
that can be done there
paprocky's passion for baseball is
hereditary
i've always been a cubs fan my mom made
sure of it
you know she brought me to my first game
when i was a few months old
she once worked as a parking attendant
here and when the family came to games
pap rocky would mimic the announcers so
can i get some announcing can you give
me like some
samples yeah ladies and gentlemen
good afternoon and welcome to baseball
here at beautiful
wrigley field that is amazing he got his
start in high school
seniors this is a reminder for seniors
and this spring when he saw the cubs job
posting on facebook
i'm here to audition he knocked it out
of the park offer you the job as the
next pa
announcer at wrigley field
wow it's like this has to be a joke in
some way or maybe i'm dreaming
so i i don't know it's right now i'm
still speechless
hopefully not too speechless he's got a
lot of talking ahead of him
adriana diaz cbs news chicago
we get set to meet the starting lineups
for today's contest
i love his voice i love his voice and
jeremiah you're not dreaming
dreams come true amazing you know i love
i just love that he got his start
announcing in the high school you know
in the hallways of his high school it's
like
i love the full circle going at two
months old and then coming back at 21
and getting the job and his mom used to
work there
but there's something about the way he
enunciates his words when it comes to
the loudspeaker
you can tell the difference between him
and bill murray we're gonna win today
it's the way he did it nicely nicely
done